Fair warning.
Today's theory will completely alter the way you watch
movies 3 through 7 Part 2
(otherwise known as 8 for any sane human), of
the Harry Potter series.
If you want to preserve
the memories of those, go binge watch
them now because after today, you will
never look at the battle between these
two wizards the same way again.
Your childhoods have been warned.
(HEDWIG'S THEME)
Hello internet!
Welcome to Film Theory,
the show where I was gonna do a
episode on Fantastic Beasts but frankly
the more I looked into that movie the
more I just wanted to go back and talk
about some good old-fashioned Harry Potter.
You know that feel when you
gotta Scamander and you just want a
little bit more Longbottom?
You know what I mean?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN!
So anyway in combing back
through the old Potter lore to piece
together the secrets of magical beasts
which will eventually become a theory
so don't get your Nifflers in a twist.
I discovered something that literally
changed everything I thought I knew
about everyone's favorite boy who lived,
and no it's not something that's an
obvious part of the story's lore,
at least I don't think so.
In a weird way,
Harry should be thanking Voldemort,
otherwise he would have just been well, Neville.
Then again that Neville one
surprised me too when I put all the
pieces together, but apparently it was old
news to a bunch of the Potterheads
but hey okay, I'm sorry I'm not the type of
person who remembers from memory what
the Dursleys were eating for
breakfast on the morning that Harry was
invited to the Quidditch World Cup!
It was grapefruit right?
I think that was grapefruit (It is MATPAT)
.
That's my answer.  Grapefruit.
Let me know in the comments if I'm right.
Anyway, theory hinges on an ancient
form of magic,
number magic, otherwise known as MATH. (oh no!)
Man, can you think about how much
more excited everyone would be to have
their 5th period class be number magic
instead of math?
Math, real talk, you got yourself
a branding problem, and heck no wonder
Harry & Co. didn't figure this one out themselves
since number magic isn't even a
subject that they're taught. (Fun fact: It's called Arithmancy in the wizarding world)
But don't you worry because
I've got you covered, so hop on those
Firebolts 'cause away we go.
For this theory we get to go back, way back...
to Harry Potter Part 6.
Long before Harry pulled the ultimate
fan boy move and named
his kid Albus Severus Potter.
*Price is Right Failure Sound*
We got this scene, where we see Tom
Riddle, otherwise known as Pre-Voldemort,
learning about splitting his soul using
dark magic: "It's called, as I understand it, a Horcrux."
It's the first time that we hear Tom Riddle
specifically mentioned Horcruxes, which
we know he later uses to divide up his
soul into neat little slices of soul pie
and shove 'em into pretty much anything he
can get his hands on from books to cups
to snakes, SNAKES not SNAPES.
Though, real talk, how awesome
would it be to have Snapes on a Plane?
Get these mo (of course)
Snapes off my mother (of course) plane!
Samuel L. Jackson must've failed potions.
Oh and by the way, this joke in fond
memory of Alan Rickman.
You are certainly missed, sir. T^T
Now, enough sadness back
to the theory, as Slughorn mentions in
the scene, Horcrux talk is no laughing matter.
"This is very dark stuff, very dark indeed."
Tom says probably what we're all
thinking: "I didn't fully understand it."
Like the cheeky little scamp
that he is, but in
all seriousness how does this work
because if you really stop to think
about it there are some pretty severe
implications to this whole Horcrux
business that goes unexplored in the
books and movies, so before we go there let
me remind you of the mechanics of
splitting your soul.
This one is for all of us who aren't
hardcore enough to have yawned their way
through the Deathly Hallows Part 1 fifteen times.
Let's be honest here for a second, we can
all agree right that Ron being gifted
and brought back by a Deluminator is a
pretty darn goofy moment right?
Am I only one who thinks that still?
Because seriously the thing just takes light
away from things; it doesn't also have
a magical teleportation device in it.
That's just random. You must be jk, J.K.
Anyway a Horcrux is an object that contains or
hides part of someone's soul, thus
allowing them to survive should someone
kill their original body.
It's like a bank but instead of money you store souls,
just like a real Bank!
Have you seen those interest rates lately?
Seriously, less than 1 percent?
What are you doing economy?
Anyway, in the scene we saw before Slughorn
dishes up some really handy exposition by
telling us that to create a Horcrux we
have to commit a murder, then somehow use
the life energy transferred during that
murder to split your own soul in half
and sort of rip part of it out of your
body and cram it into the nearest
object of your choice.
Preferably something with a little
staying power and not that week old
block of cheese in the back your fridge,
though, I will admit that thing's been in
there for a while and at this point I
ain't touchin' it, so perhaps that cheese is
the safest vessel for that soul.
Anyway, based on info from the
books and the movies, the
The actual mechanics of soul cutting and
soul transferring are a bit hazy,
but it's not
like we're writing an eHow page on
the subject.
We get the general point
that when you create a Horcrux you're
splitting your soul in half between your
body and an object and that tells us
everything we need for today's theory, so
Tom Riddle and (Professor) Slughorn talk about
splitting the soul into seven pieces but
we all assumed that it's seven equal pieces.
It is most definitely not.
Every time Voldemort splits his soul in half,
he only leaves half of his remaining soul
in his own body; then, the next time he
creates a Horcrux, it splits in half
again.  Over and over.
So what does that mean?
Well, let's walk
through some history that must not be
named to see how it all plays out.
He starts in 1943 with one whole soul.
This conversation with Slughorn happens
after the school year starts in 1943
when Tom is 16 years old.
In The Chamber of Secrets, we learned that Tom Riddle
puts his 16-year old soul into his diary.
Thus creating the first Horcrux.
To create this Horcrux, he kills Moaning
Myrtle which we also confirm when he
describes her killer as a boy speaking
a strange language.
"But they said something funny, a kind
of made up language."
(A Tom Riddle speaking Parseltongue)
With one Horcrux made, he who must
need a rhinoplasty is down to 50
percent of a soul, with the other 50
percent locked into the diary.
At this point we know then that The Diary is the
Horcrux that contains the largest
percentage of Voldemort.
After that, the creation of each Horcrux is
supposedly tied to a major murder
committed by Tom, at least according to
J.K. Rowling in a rule that we'll see
her break in just under 45 seconds.
Now when Tom kills his father, Tom Riddle
Senior, he creates the Marvolo Gaunt
Ring Horcrux which we see on his
finger in the scene with Slughorn.
This is around the time of him creating the diary
also when he's either 16 or 17, and since
we're taking half the soul Voldemort has
remaining this means that the Gaunt Ring
has 25 percent Tom and Tom
himself is down to 25 percent,
and with his prospects rapidly falling.
Next, he kills Hepzibah. Hepzibah.
I don't know how to say your name Hepzibah but
I'm gonna say it that way
cause it's fun to say.
Next he kills Hepzibah Smith in
1945 followed by a random muggle like
I said, J.K. breaking your own rule.
Anyway, two characters aren't really in
the movies but were confirmed in a web
interview with JK Rowling's in 2007.
Tom bumps them both off and splits his soul into
the Hufflepuff Cup that we see in Goblet of
Fire and the Slytherin Locket that shows
up at the Sirius Black Estate, so these
Horcruxes have 12.5
percent soul and 6.25 percent soul with Tom
himself being down to 6.25 percent.
If you think about what that means that's
actually not surprising that as he rises
to power you see him start to physically
change in response to his soul being drained.
If you could lose over
ninety-five percent of your soul and
only really be missing some skin pigment,
your hair, and your nose, that's not such
a bad trade-off for immortality all
things considered. I'm just saying.
Anyway, the next Horcrux is in 1956, The
Ravenclaw Diadem. (The subber is a Ravenclaw) We know Voldemort. (Ravenclaw squad where you at?)
shows back up at Hogwarts at this point
to ask Dumbledore to become the Defense
Against the Dark Arts teacher which
Dumbledore turns him down for.
After that, Voldermort, get this,
curses the position and everyone who
holds it from then on,
hence the reason why every year there's
a new teacher in the position.
I honestly didn't know this until reading up on all
the lore bits on the Pottermore site.
Isn't that insane? Voldermort is like
the sorest loser ever,
and it's worth mentioning that this is
probably Voldermort's most effective
spell of the entire series.
Anyway, JK Rowling has also confirmed in several
interviews that Voldemort cursed the
position and the curse wasn't broken until he died,
and since he was in the neighborhood
anyway, he hid the Diadem Horcrux in the
Room of Requirement, which despite what he
says about it in the book, was
ridiculously easy to find.
Here's a bright idea.
Let me hide this
item in a room that, if someone is
required to kill me, will make sure it
shows up right in time for that person,
what an excellent hiding spot!
Then again I suppose he required that the room needed
to be hidden so he wouldn't die so
really we just have the Room of
Requirement playing favorites now.
I see, of course, you too are choosing Team Harry.
Anyway, short story even shorter if
Malfoy hadn't shown up, the whole
thing would have taken like three
minutes, but I digress.
What's important here that by age 30
Voldemort's soul is down to 3.125
percent of his original soul, and despite
talking about this grand plan to split
soul into seven pieces; he must absolutely
suck at counting because he actually quits at six.
Five items and his original soul.
Way to do a job only 857 hundredths of the way,
Voldie, because yeah at that point
Voldemort takes a little siesta for
about 30 years.
I don't know, maybe he's afraid of more
appendages falling off, so there's no
other Horcrux creation until 1981.
That's the moment when Voldemort attacks Harry Potter,
and that's not even intentional Horcrux creation.
I don't think this guy was ever
gonna get to seven.  By the way, just as a side
note anyone else realize that Voldemort
is 54 when he attacks Harry?
I always just assumed that he was in
like his thirties,
and that is still decades before the book.
He is literally 70 when we see him
returning to power.  That is crazy.
People give the guy a hard time for
looking as rough as he does?
Pfff. Come on.  If I'm looking like that when
I'm 70 then I must've had some plastic
surgery done because he's really missing
key features of his face.
Also worth mentioning, in real life Harry Potter
would be almost 40.
Ugghhhh makes me feel sad and old.
Regardless, we all know the
story, when Harry Potter and Voldemort
meet, Voldemort's spell rebounds and he
inadvertently splits his soul again
making Harry the unintentional Horcrux.
Now, there's some debate about the actual
Horcruxiness of Harry, but in a
web interview with J.K. Rowling on the
Leaky Cauldron site, she directly
confirms that Harry Potter is indeed
the last unintentional Horcrux, so for
this episode I'm with her.
The important part here that when the
attack happens Voldemort's soul splits again.
His body basically vaporizes and
turns that remaining 1.5625 percent of
soul into some kind of weird wafting
spirit that later attaches to the back
of Professor Quirrell's head like some
sort of face leech.
This also means that we've pinpointed exactly
how much Voldermort is in Harry.
Just over 1.5 percent.
Maybe that's what Harry's scar really is,
just a little soul schmutz on his
forehead, ya got a little something, just uhh lick
your thumb and a li'l something right
there that uhh... Let me just ... since you don't have a
mother I have to do it for you.
OOOHH that hurts.
So what does all this tell us when the
Harry Potter series starts?
Well, first that the whole Potter series is predicated on
a 1.5 percent soul blob, which does seem to take
a little bit away from the gravitas of
this series.
It also tells us that when Harry's
destroying Horcruxes, some of them
matter a whole lot more than others.
The very first one that Harry destroys
is actually the biggest deal because it
contains literally half of Voldermort.
Half. Fifty percent. More than any other
Horcrux, and way more than Voldemort
himself at the end of the series, so in
reality, by the end of book 2, Voldermort
is mathematically, mostly dead.
From there, the Horcruxes go on to be destroyed in
pretty much the same order that they
were created, effectively knocking out
96.875 percent of Voldemort's soul
before the final movie even begins.
Alright, but I hear you remembering your
Harry Potter movie trivia and ya'll see
what I'm leaving out here.
It's not the elephant in the room;
it's the SNAKE. Any true Potterite knows
that Nagini is also a
Horcrux in the series, but one that I
haven't mentioned yet at all.
Well here's why. Nagini was created
in 1994, 13 years after his
run-in with Harry Potter.
During Harry's fourth year, Nagini  becomes
Voldermort's last attempt to split his
soul into even more tiny little soul
crumbs, but what this means for this
series is the really fascinating part
because at this point with the creation
of the final Horcrux, Voldemort's soul
splits one final time leaving him with
only 0.78 percent; less than
1 percent of his original soul, meaning that
Nagini has the other 0.78 percent.
With so little so left, it's no
wonder that Voldy can't effectively use the
Elder Wand at the end of the series.
Yeah, yeah, I know that the actual
explanation given in the movies is about
disarming the Elder Wand from other
Wizards, but that is a whole 'nother
episode unto itself my friends, but  what's even
more shocking about this reveal is that
it means that Harry Potter himself,
starting in the fourth movie and through
to the end of series is more
Voldemort than Voldermort.
In fact, he's literally
twice the Voldemort Voldermort is!
From the fourth movie onward, Tommy Riddle is
at 0.78 percent soul.
Harry, from his birth is rocking out at
1.5 percent Voldemort,
and when you stop to think about it that
way the last battles of this series are really anticlimactic.
They are literally battling over a villain with a
health bar of less than 1 percent.
In this epic battle for Hogwarts, the grand evil
wizard is just a fraction of a fraction
of a fraction, so there you have it.
Definitive mathematical proof supported
by the author and the lore that Harry
Potter is more Voldermort than the actual
Voldermort in the Harry Potter series.
Makes you look at him a bit differently, huh?
Every time ya see Harry on screen you're
literally looking at the largest percent
of Dark Lord walking around in the whole series.
Oh yea, and if you want one final thing
that will completely ruin the way that
you look at Harry Potter from here on
out, Daniel Radcliffe starred in the
broadway production of Equus in which
he rides horses
around naked, so on have fun Google image
searching that one.
Put away your wand Harry!
Put it away! but
Hey, that's just a theory... a Film Theory!
and cut!... Accio subscribe button and
remember it's called subscribE button
and not subscriBE the so please perform
the magic of your own and click that
subscribe button like I mentioned with
Fantastic Beasts being a new series
you can bet theories are on their way
about that one and if subscribing ain't
your thing, well then do me a favor
click on your favorite character,
Harry, Ron, or Hermione,
Consider this the SUPER
AMAZING END CARD TOURNAMENT.
Choose whichever one, I'm just curious which one
is your favorite.
Hermione, definitely mine. I mean she's
got a great brain on her just sayin' so
please click subscribe if you haven't,
make sure he cast your vote on your
favorite character, and now if you'll
excuse me I have a new theory to work on,
I'll see you next week with something
that's a bit more sinister and blonde.